dieses video dient lediglich dem zweck
der unterhaltung ist zum gänzlichen
sinne humoristisch zu sehen keine der
nachfolgen getroffenen aussagen
repräsentieren unsere persönliche
meinung die selber finden solche pranke
daher wollten wir die szene hiermit auf
die schippe nehmen viel spaß
hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
real live video mir war heute morgen ein
wenig langweilig vor mir ist so
langweilig und ihr wisst ja dass ich ein
großer fan von frank m
deswegen wollte ich heute mal den gold
cup rang in der stadt aufnehmen
natürlich benötigt man darf auch ein
passendes auto daher habe ich meine spaß
in die hand genommen und mir dieses
wunderbare automobil zugelegt
der goldpreis funktioniert sodass ich
hässliches entlein zu verschiedenen
schicksale die hingehe und sie nach
einem date frage sofern nicht an eine
abfuhr bekommen sollte werde ich zu
meinem lamborghini gehen und schauen wie
die frauen reagieren zwei stunden später
in der innenstadt
hey du ich bin neu in der stadt kannst
mir sagen wo man hier eventuell was
essen gehen kann
wer bist du russland ist punkt hallo
mein name ist luca und ich hab echt
hunger gerade darum geht ist ein guter
witz laden kaufe ich meine alleine essen
macht keinen spaß mich vielleicht
begleichen
als neueste panel soll es eine anmache
sein oder was außer ich wollte ich jetzt
nicht belästigen wo ich hab ein freund
ja und der fed an drei abenden gut dann
fahre ich halt alleine deine schnauze
barbie
zwei stunden später in der innenstadt
davon bekommt noch erledigen da testen
jetzt auch direkt nochmal hallo mein
name ist luca und wer bist du an lianen
ich bin die steller ich bin neu in der
stadt und hat es schon immer lust auf
einen sohn weißt du wo ich einen krieg
oder wollen wir einen machen also dir
jemand einen sohn gebären würde ich
bitte dich aber aber
und jetzt geht zurück zu deiner mama
okay dann fahre ich mal hin so ein
doofer blödmann was erlaubt er sich
darf ich mal mitfahren dein schmerz ist
ja okay wir haben heute gelernt das
tolle frauen nur geld aus mit dem ja
freunde das war es heute vom heutigen
video wir haben uns wirklich einfach nur
gedacht bequeme weise besser als wir
kaufen uns einfach mal ein paar
barbiepuppen weg auf unsere lamborghini
und stellen diesen gold gebracht ihr
wahrscheinlich schon am anfang in
disclaimer gelesen das soll jetzt
überhaupt kein held sein gegen ähnliche
leute gegen gold digger krank machen
also ich bin halt selber nicht so der
riesen fan von solchen prank weil ich
einfach irgendwie als als gewissenhaft
ich ansehen
wir wollten das ganze mit so ein
bisschen auf die schippe nehmen und
vielleicht hat sich ja gefallen wenn es
das getan hat und die eventuell noch
mehr mit diesen barbiepuppen sehen wollt
freuen wir uns über eine bewertung an
der stelle auch danke für max von phil
hay klar bank und dann sehen wir uns zu
fahren in einem nächsten chef